prayer indeed is a mystery have you ever
felt that as you were kneeling and you
prayed your prayers hit the ceiling and
kind of bounce back at your feet have
you ever felt that you've been praying
into some dark hole in space and you've
wondered is there anybody out there
listening
prayer indeed is a mystery have you ever
felt that as you were kneeling and you
prayed your prayers hit the ceiling and
kind of bounce back at your feet have
you ever felt that you've been praying
into some dark hole in space and you've
wondered is there anybody out there
listening now one thing is for certain
the Bible is clear on the importance of
intercessory prayer the Apostle Paul was
in prison in Rome and he wrote to the
church at
Philippi and he shared with this church
his concern his burden for them and he
says in Philippians chap 1 I thank my
God verse three upon every remembrance
of you always in every prayer of mine
making request for you all with joy Paul
says here I am in in a dark damp dingy
dungeon in Rome but I'm kneeling here in
this dungeon I'm praying for you and as
I pray for you I believe my prayers are
going up to heaven and I'm praying that
God will strengthen you I'm praying that
you'll constantly have a greater
knowledge of his will that the eyes of
your understanding will be open to know
his word and to be sensitive to his
Spirit Paul believed in intercessory
prayer when you come to the book of
Colossians for
example Colossians 1 verse3 now again
Paul's praying for the church at
colossia we give thanks to God and
father of our Lord Jesus Christ praying
always for you since we heard of your
faith Paul says to the Church of
colossia we're praying for you let's go
to the book of Ephesians here in
Ephesians the first chapter just as Paul
prayed for the church at Philippi just
as he prayed for the church at kalasia
so he's praying for the church at
Ephesus and he says in Ephesians chapter
1 verse 15 and onward therefore I also
after I heard of your faith in the Lord
Jesus and your love of all the saints do
not cease to give thanks for you making
mention of you in my prayers one thing
we notice about the apostle Paul in his
prayers they're very very specific Paul
prayed for the church at Philippi at
times Paul prayed for specific people he
prayed for the church at kalasia again
at times he prayed for specific people
and here he prays for the church at
Ephesus now when we pray does God always
answer our
prayers what prayers can we pray that we
can have absolute assurance that God
will answer and what prayers might be a
little bit iffy and what prayers won't
he answer that's an important question
An important series of questions
actually so let's go to First John
chapter 5 I think this is one of the
most significant uh chap chapters in all
the Bible on prayer and this passage is
certainly one of my favorites on prayer
first John that's right before the Book
of Revelation 5:4 and onward this is the
confidence we have in him now where is
our confidence is our confidence in our
prayers not at all is our confidence in
our faith not at all this is the
confidence we have where in him now
notice if we ask anything according to
his will he hears us and if we know that
he hears us whatever we ask we know that
we have the petitions we desired of him
is there a qualification In this passage
this is the confidence that we have in
in him if we ask what anything according
what to his will he hears us now what
are the things in the Bible that we know
are according to God's will we know it's
according to his will to forgive our
sins if we confess our sins he's
faithful and just to forgive us our sins
1 John 1 verse 9 so if we confess he'll
forgive so when I come to Jesus on my
knees or lying there in my bed and say
Lord I failed you I lost my temper Lord
I wasn't really honest in this instance
Lord some of the things I watched on
television we not in harmony with your
will Lord forgive me do I have to say oh
Jesus if it's your will forgive me not
at all because we know it's his will to
forgive our sins all of the spiritual
blessings that he offers us are
according to his will so we don't have
to ask him if it is his will for the
spiritual blessings of Heaven what are
they the forgiveness of sin we can pray
and believe our sins are forgiven not
because we feel forgiven but because we
trust his word we may still feel guilty
at times we may still feel the
condemning voice of our conscience but
that has little to do with it we believe
that we are forgiven that our guilt is
gone Romans 8 vers1 there is no
condemnation to those that are in Christ
Jesus what else we know is according to
his will his power to enable us to
overcome sin so when we pray for victory
over an evil temper we say oh God if
it's your will give me Victory not at
all when we pray for victory over some
Habit in our life like Alcohol Tobacco
we know it is Will is his will we can
claim that Victory because he's promised
to give it to us the Bible says I can do
all things Philippians 4 verse 13 I can
do all things through Christ that
strengthens me I remember one time I was
helping a man quit smoking and as I was
talking to about these great Promises of
God this is the confidence that we have
in him if we ask anything according to
his will he hears us I asked him is it
God's will for you to quit smoking well
yes do you believe that you can quit
well I'm not sure wait a minute you're
not sure what does God's word say this
is the Comm confidence we have where in
him where is the confidence Joe is is it
in your strength no is it in your
ability to quit no where's your
confidence in him will you place your
your faith in him yes Pastor I will okay
get your get your tobacco he got his
tobacco brought it here we put it on the
floor one pack of cigarettes we offered
up this prayer dear Lord we know that
it's your will we know it's your will to
deliver Joe we know that you have power
Lord in the Name of Christ deliver him
now as I was praying I didn't think much
above it about it but I had my hands
over his cigarettes I picked them up and
put them in my pocket that's the first
time I think in my life I ever had
cigarettes in my pocket and as I was
left his house with those cigarettes in
my pocket what I didn't know and his
mother told me later he he called his
mother he said mom you never guess
what's what happened you'll never guess
what's happened she said what is it
Pastor Finley prayed a prayer for the
power of God to come down in my life and
take away my desire for tobacco and to
give me victory over tobacco and Pastor
when I when I opened my eyes mama my
cigarettes were gone the the Angels must
have taken them well they were actually
in my pocket I didn't think much about
it he thought the Angels took his
cigarettes I never had quite the heart
to tell him what actually happened that
day but God did give him the Victory and
we saw that man go into the water and
baptize in name of the Father the Son
and the Holy Spirit you say what did you
ever do with those those cigarettes well
I got rid of them of
course if we
pray according to God's will we can ask
God for any of the spiritual
blessings that are available to us in
Christ in Christ all the spiritual
blessings of Heaven are available that
includes forgiveness of sin that
includes freedom from guilt that
includes peace of mind that includes
freedom from worry and anxiety that
includes strength in our life that
includes power in our life that includes
God's guidance in our life Psalm 32:8
says that I will guide you with M eye
God promises to guide us Isaiah 58:1
says I'll guide you continually so I
don't have to get on my knees as a
Christian oh God if it's your will guide
me no he promises now what are some of
the things that we do not
necessarily have as Assurance when we
pray let's
suppose that it's a beautiful bommy
summer day and you want to go on a
picnic but clouds come over and you
begin to pray dear Lord dear Lord I want
to go on that picnic and Lord I because
I want to go on that picnic Lord I know
it's not going to rain but across the
street from your house there's a farmer
and it hasn't rained for three weeks and
he's praying oh Lord I need rain for my
crops please send the rain you see in
those instances I don't know whether
it's best for me to go on that picnic or
not so I pray Lord if it is your will
hold back the weather there was a time
that I was a young man in Heartford
Connecticut I was a young Pastor my wife
was teaching at a Christian School and
there was a dear elderly Pastor there
that was holding a Revival week his name
was WD
fry and I learned the power of prayer
then as we were going to have our
meeting that night many people were
coming and we knew that they needed to
hear the message that Pastor FY was
going to preach but as we looked at the
news dark clouds were gathering it was
supposed to
snow very heavily and we knew that that
would inhibit the meetings and very few
people would come and I shall never
forget it Pastor frie got on his knees
he prayed a simple prayer dear Lord you
know that these people need to hear this
message tonight and I am praying
according to your will you are wiser
than we are God but I'm praying that you
would not let it snow over this city and
our venue that day something very
surprising happened even the weathermen
were surprised it snowed all around the
city snowed in the suburbs but it did
not
snow over our meeting but we prayed in
God's will now there are there any
things that for example we might pray at
times thinking they're God's will but
they're actually not a good example of
that is the Apostle Paul since the
Apostle Paul was blinded uh and had
problems with his eyesight after the
Damascus Road experience where he saw
that bright light he evidently had some
problems there with his eyesight he
prayed that God would remove that burden
from him of dimmed Vision we read about
the story here
in the book of Corinthians 2 Corinthians
and we're looking there at 2 Corinthians
12 there is something more important in
life than our healing when we are
afflicted with disease it could be
cancer heart disease diabetes any other
significant
disease God invites us to come to pray
to pray for healing to pray for strength
but there are times that God does not
always heal because there's something
more important to God than our healing
and that is our Salvation And there are
times that God allows us to go through
very difficult trials in our life to
draw us closer to him in 2 Corinthians
12 we read Paul has this thorn in his
flesh and that's probably his eyesight
his physical problem second Corinthians
12:7 and lest I should be exalted above
measure by the abundance of Revelations
a thorn in the flesh was given to me a
messenger of Satan to buffer me lest I
be exalted above measure now who gave
Paul this Thorn In the Flesh that we
think was the eyesight problem who gave
Paul that he said it's a messenger of
Satan well if it's a messenger of Satan
wouldn't God necessarily remove it now
this passage is really helpful because
it tells us that God is not the author
of sickness suffering heartache or death
that's always the messenger of Satan
sickness is not something that God
afflicts us with but let's look here at
2 Corinthians
12:8 concerning this thing I pleaded
with the Lord now Paul says I'm pleading
with the Lord he's not just casually
praying but he's pleading with the Lord
he's earnestly praying and he doesn't
only do it once three times that it
might depart from me and he said to me
my grace is sufficient for you my
strength is made perfect in weakness
therefore most gladly will I rather
boast in my infirmities that the power
of Christ May rest upon me therefore I
take pleasure in infirmities reproaches
needs persecutions distresses for
Christ's sake for when I'm weak then I'm
strong so Paul prays three times that he
would be healed three times that the
Affliction of the disease would be
removed but God says my grace is
sufficient for thee my strength is made
perfect in weakness so there are times
that God is going to miraculously heal I
have seen that happen on a number of
occasions when I've anointed people I
remember on one occasion I was at a
large youth meeting and one of the youth
leaders was afflicted with paral Isis he
was taken to the hospital he they
believed he had had a stroke paralyzed
on one side could not talk we anointed
him before the anointing I gathered with
the doctors and they said this is a very
difficult case but we anointed that
young man and God worked a miracle of
healing on other instances I've anointed
and people have not been miraculously
healed but here's what we know if you
pray for healing and you're not healed
like the apost OST Paul was not healed
God will give you the strength to handle
the Affliction that you have and his
grace and Glory will be manifest in your
life so there are times that it takes
more faith to trust God in sickness than
it does to be healed by God in that
Affliction as we trust him in that
sickness we reveal to the doctors and
nurses of other others around us his
strength his power his glory when we
release our bodies to God remember what
the Apostle Paul said in Romans 12:1 I
beseech you therefore Brethren to
present your bodies a Living Sacrifice
so when we release our bodies to God as
a Living Sacrifice we say God you can do
whatever you want with this body it's
yours you created me you redeemed it on
Calvary it is yours Lord I'd love to be
healed miraculously but if you choose
not to heal
I want to Reveal Your Grace your
strength and your power so sometimes God
does not answer our prayers the way we
want why because he wants to reveal
himself in ways known only to him he
wants to fill our hearts with Grace with
strength with power he wants his glory
to be revealed through us now there are
other reasons why God may not answer
prayer the way we think he ought to
because there may be something in our
life that is a roadblock something in
our life that inhibits that answer we
find that principle in Psalm 66 and
verse 18 the scripture says if I regard
now notice the word regard that's
cherish if I regard iniquity in my heart
the Lord will not hear but certainly God
has heard me so David says if I regard
if do what regard cherish if there's
cherish sin in my life and I pray for a
miracle in my life God will not hear why
not because if he did he would be
endorsing the sin in my life so there's
something more important than the
immediate answer to the prayer that I'm
praying it is the prayer to ask God to
help me to overcome the sin in my life
that I'm dealing with so if I regard sin
so if if you are praying and you're
finding you're not get many answers to
your
prayers get on your knees and say God is
there something in my life that is
inhibiting those answers is there
something in my life that's holding back
those answers is there something in my
life that's keeping me from getting the
answers at times God uses prayer as a
lever to pry sin out of our lives so as
we're praying and we find ourselves not
getting many answers We Begin asking
ourselves the question is there
something deep in my life that I don't
understand is there some habit that is
not in harmony with God's will that I've
not confronted yet that I'm cherishing
is there some attitude in my life that
I'm cherishing so sometimes we don't get
answers to our prayers because of some
sin in our lives and God leads us to
know that sin so we can deal with it and
we can ask him for power and we don't
ask have to ask if it's God's will we we
ask him to forgive us we ask for power
to overcome that thing now there some
other there's another reason why we may
not get immediate answers to our prayers
and that is found in James the Book of
James James chapter 3 and here's another
reason why we may not always get
immediate answers to our
prayers we find it here and the Bible is
very clear it helps us to work through
these issues James and we're going to
look actually at chapter four not three
but four James chapter 4
where do Wars and fights come from among
you don't they come from your desires
your
pleasure for pleasure that war and your
members you lust and do not have you
murmur and covet and cannot obtain you
fight and War yet you do not have
because you do not ask you ask and do
not receive why because you ask a miss
that you may spend it on your pleasures
so here's what James is saying he's
saying if you ask for selfish reasons if
I'm on my knees saying oh Lord I really
need a car but I'd love a Mercedes
please send one Lord or Lord I would
really like uh a new a new suit but is
the what's my motive in that is the is
is my liking the new suit to uh dress
pleasantly for Christ uh to reflect his
glory because I want to be neat and
attractive or is it to satisfy a selfish
need so if if we desire it's like okay
Lord I'm praying that my favorite sports
team will win well in the light of the
controversy between good and evil in the
light of the struggle and the battle
between Christ and Satan in the light of
earthquakes and famines and fires and
floods and children that are starving in
the light of everything that we could
ask God are we asking him that our
favorite sports team will win what about
the people pray playing praying for the
other sports team so if we ask simply to
accomplish it and put it on our own lust
if it's if it's that kind of asking uh
simply for own pleasure we may not get
answers now there are times though that
we pray and there's no apparent answer
but God is working out the answer in
other words we're praying and there may
be no apparent answer to our prayers
we're praying and there may be nothing
that we can really see going on but
there's a controversy behind the scenes
between Christ and Satan do we have an
example of that in the Bible we do
Daniel Daniel knew that the time of
Jeremiah's captivity the prophecy of
Jeremiah's captivity was up for the
nation of Israel he was praying that his
people would be set free from the
bondage first of Babylon and then meet
of Persia and as Daniel Prayed first day
no apparent answer to the prayer second
day no answer Third Day prayed for a
week no apparent
answer two weeks no answer three weeks
no answer you say wait wait a minute
that's like me that's like some my
prayers I've been praying and there's
not much an answer but look what happens
in Daniel chapter 10 Daniel chapter 10
we're looking there and
uh Daniel's praying and uh Daniel 10:12
the angel comes down and he said do not
fear Daniel from the first day that you
set your heart to understand and to
humble yourself before God your words
were heard and I've come because of your
words now this is an amazing passage
danius prayed for three weeks and then
eventually this being of dazzling
brightness comes down and Daniel faints
it was actually the Lord himself and
then another being Taps Daniel on the
shoulder it's the angel and he wakes
Daniel up and he said from the first day
you prayed I came and answered to your
prayers but there's a problem and he
explains to Daniel that there was a
battle over the mind of Cyrus uh Satan
tried to influence the king not to sign
the decree and as this battle took place
back and forth between Satan's forces
and the forces of of Heaven these two
angelic forces fought and the Angelic
forces we wanting to beat back the evil
forces the Heavenly Angels we're going
to beat back the evil angels so that
Cyrus's mind would be clear and not
influenced by evil so he had signed the
decree that and as Daniel Prayed and
prayed and prayed those angels kept
fighting and battling and finally Jesus
himself came down and chased away the
evil angels so there are times that we
pray you may pray for a son or a
daughter a husband or a wife that
doesn't know Christ and as you're
praying there's a great battle between
good and evil over their minds now
something will happen when we pray that
wouldn't happen if we didn't pray great
controversy a wonderful book says in
page 525 God will do an answer to the
prayer of faith that which he wouldn't
do if we did not thus pray so God is
doing everything he can to reach your
son your daughter your husband your wife
your neighbor your working associate
your friend who doesn't know Christ but
when we pray God does more than he would
have done otherwise why because God is
limited by their Free Will and their
choice but when we pray God looks at
Satan and he says Mark Finley is praying
John is praying Sam is praying George is
praying and when when we pray it opens
up new avenues of new Vistas for God to
do something miraculous in the life of
the one that we're praying for so when
you pray and you don't get immediate
answers recognize there's a battle
between good and evil there's Christ
there's a battle between Christ and
Satan sometimes when we go through
trials and difficulties and challenges
like we mentioned in health maybe there
won't be an immediate answer but maybe
our continued prayer does two things one
it provides us Grace and strength to
face what we have to face and secondly
it teaches us persistence in prayer
perseverance in prayer so when your
prayers are not immediately answered
begin to examine your heart to see if
there's any sin in there that keeps them
from being answered analyze your motives
why do I want this thing to happen is it
for the glory of God or is it for my own
pleasure claim the promises of God
believing in indeed that he will answer
recognize for all the spiritual
blessings of heaven we need not ask his
will we simply claim those promises by
faith and remember too how the Lord puts
it in Psalm 50 verse 15 Jesus loves to
have us come to him he loves to have us
kneel at his throne he loves to have us
believe Psalm 50 and verse 15 The Script
says call upon me in the day of trouble
I will deliver you and you shall glorify
me the purpose of answered prayer is to
bring glory to God he says call on me in
the day of trouble and I'll answer you
and you shall glorify me I love the way
Jesus puts it in Luke chapter 11 he says
if you being evil know how to give good
gifts to your children how much more are
will your heavenly father give the Holy
Spirit to those that ask I love that
phrase how much more Jesus wants to do
much more for you than you can
imagine Jesus longs to answer our
prayers he says ask and it shall be
given to you seeking you shall find
knock and it shall be open unto you come
to
Jesus with all your wants all your needs
all your anxieties come with your
difficulties and your problems come with
your sin and your guilt come in your
weakness and your Frailty but come come
to the one that created heavens and the
Earth come to the almighty all powerful
God come to the Christ that hung on
calvary's cross with outstretched hands
dying for you come to the one that
redeemed you come to the high priest in
heaven who is there living for you
whose ear is bent low to hear your every
prayer to meet your every need come to
the one who's coming again for you come
with open heart and open mind come
filled with faith
knowing that he will answer every
sincere honest prayer come knowing that
the richest blessings of Heaven are
yours let's pray Father in heaven we
thank you the the richest blessings of
Heaven are ours we thank you we can come
and ask you for forgiveness and power
and strength and peace thank you that we
can come and trust you knowing that
sometimes our apparently unanswered
prayers are being answered as you battle
in this controversy between good and
evil and you chase back the forces of
Hell come and let us know that even if
our prayers are not answered in the way
we think they ought to be that you're
working work to give us strength to
handle the situation that we've been
praying for thank you that you're a
loving God thank you that you're a
willing God thank you that you invite us
to come to receive your strength and
power and thank you that you're a God
who does answer our prayers in Jesus
name amen